I just don't want to put any more stress
on my family
this particular does lend itself to
watching it in a theatrical space
because there's a certain energy that
and maybe a safety in numbers
kind of quality to it I mean I like to
watch the films that I make because I
like to see not only what I did but what
everybody's efforts has accumulated and
become what it's turned into and I loved
it it is just as exciting as how it was
to me when I initially read it it did
like it has taken on this palpable
energy and people there's a real
interest in it and I really feel it
comes from its re its re ester this is a
man he should not forget it's his first
feature and he is the real deal he is a
true artist and an absolutely hugely
talented author and he's made something
highly original and the very fact that
it is a genre piece but it is so natural
and emotional and honest and raw take
care of me you don't think I'm gonna
take care of you when you die is our
scream queen no I guess I'm like the
contrary nature of some of the
characters I've played with in that
I mean in hereditary I'm playing a woman
who yes is a mother and she is so
unlikable at times and I think there are
certain expectations and idealized
notions about motherhood and this just
like throws them out the window and I
think that's important actually to know
that it's not always this rosy time for
women and it's obviously a confronting
time because the whole family is
navigating this profound loss and I
think people are really vulnerable and
lost at that moment in their lives and
their behavior can be very very
questionable because they're so hurt you
okay man just like they're happy
something you wanna say
I never wanted to be your mother an in
general and I'm asked that question
about which what kind of character would
you like to play it's really difficult
to answer because people the characters
that I like to play are just as complex
as we are as humans and then so you
can't really say that type of person no
because it's too complicated so when it
is complicated that's what I'm excited
about sometimes I swear I can feel
I saw it at South by Southwest with an
audience and then last night I went to
sorry I didn't interesting experience
for last night I went to a screening but
I didn't see the movie I just went at
the end and I just watched people's
faces as the movie ended and they got up
and they just looked you know white they
just the blood was gone from their face
soundtrack o'clock it's really
interesting because it's such a subtle
way of getting a message across that you
don't always see usually it's like
writing on a wall literally that says I
am here or something like that and it's
just like a really great way of getting
it across and still making you uneasy
but not really knowing if it did happen
and you're just like what is happening
basically I said to our I know how to do
that scene and I said art as I came it
I'll do it on a real desk like you can
give me real test I'll do and he was
like I appreciate it and I love you but
pretty sure that's illegal and I don't
need to break your nose actually I was
like okay man yeah that's understandable
like and he was like it so he's like
we'll get you a soft one I'm like okay
so I prepared that I'm like I'm really
hitting on the soft one and then the day
they brought something that it was not a
soft one by any means it had like a foam
cover but then it was really hard
underneath it was like so I just really
slammed my face and they only had two of
them so I just so like went for it and
sort of blacked out blood is gushing
down fake blood and then down my knee is
real blood because I hit my knee so hard
and I can't move my elbow and my foot is
swollen and I'm like limping I'm like an
arse like dude we got it I'm like great
I'm gonna my trailer and I'm never doing
it again like for like a week afterwards
I was like what is happening what am i
doing I still don't have a completely
figured out and that's something that I
love because I keep thinking about it
Rosemary's Baby for sure and I think
that's what this is most similar to and
I think that's my favorite
[Music]